[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a comedian and the author
of jews don't count david badil welcome
to trigonometry
hello everybody hello guys hello
constantine hello francis
nice to see you um can i just say i've
got a new camera
um yeah i normally do podcasts over
there on that sofa
just with a laptop but i bought a new
logitech camera
so there's quite a lot of depth of field
going on and also i'm worried already
and it's like an erotic jewish way that
it shows bits of my study the people
thinking what the [ __ ] is that like what
is that big
trophy over there why is he put that
there is that
to say that he won the fa cup once it's
not it's a trophy that
i got for winning richard osmond's house
of games
and i don't i didn't know where else to
put it and also these things
people are going to be thinking what are
they does he have some sort of
disability
they're not that's something i bought
because i do that quite a lot
i've actually got a podcast i do with
faye ripley about just buying [ __ ] on
the internet
and talking about it and what that is is
a chair gym
right and you're meant to be able to do
this with these stuff hang on
wait a minute this is
this is the best opening in the history
of trigonometry mate i've got to say
yeah so you can both be lazy and get
ripped at the same time
that's the idea all my life i've looked
for
gadgets that could do that for me and
none of them have ever actually worked
as you could tell but yeah i am the
laziest
uh worker outer in the world and i'm
always trying to take shortcuts there
apart from that i think it looks all
right so you know yeah no it looks great
and
it's good to have you man uh thanks for
coming on the show we really appreciate
it
i i should say for anyone who's not
familiar we'll maybe get you to talk a
little bit about your your career
and life story as well uh the the title
of the book jews don't count it's not
like a policy prescription
uh just in case anyone from america has
tuned in and go
finally someone's saying it you know
like that that's
not what it is there was
some troll who when it first came out
he wasn't really talking to me he was
talking to i think daniel finkelstein
who people
will possibly know a little bit in
britain but won't know
he's actually a lord he's a tory peer
and jewish and he was talking about the
book and some bloke claiming to be
jewish had kept on saying
that's hate speech uh i'm going to go
to the police to get this book shut down
you know who would read this book on the
tube
i mean that is a good look just sitting
on the tube reading a book saying jews
don't count
yeah i mean if you do take it literally
as opposed to what it clearly is which
is
reported speech summing up an attitude
that i feel is prevalent
but just as a manifesto i can see his
point but he is the only person who
seems to have taken it that way
yeah so it's not us it's not a
prescription
uh from a very disaffected jew uh as to
how we should proceed re-use no it's
summing up the attitude that i'm
critiquing
well we'll talk about that in a sec but
as i mentioned before we started we have
a very large international audience a
lot of people
in in the uk for people abroad david is
a is a very well-known comedian who's
created lots of stuff that people
uh really love and us included uh but
tell everybody a little bit about
your life story david just you know how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life
well yeah i'm a comedian i've done lots
of stuff i'm quite old
56 and uh i
you know started out as a stand-up
comedian and then after doing that for a
few years i
got on telly in britain with a show
called the merry white house experience
which was a stand-up and sketch show
and that blew up quite in quite a big
way and me and a guy called rob newman
became the first ever british comedians
to play wembley arena
which was great amazing uh and then me
and him split up quite badly
and i then started another show with
another comedian in britain called frank
skinner
which is about football it's called
fantasy football league and that did
well as well
and uh i'm probably best i hate best
known
for like one of the things as you grow
older is the notion that the phrase best
known for
is what's going to be on the news when
you die
and uh i love this thing that i did but
i do know it will be on the news when i
die and that is
me and frank and a bank of the lightning
seeds uh wrote a song called three lions
which was adopted as the kind of english
football anthem
in the 90s and probably still is the
best known football
pop song of all time and it was sung by
you know crowds at wembley and all the
rest of it and still is
uh and then sort of lately i've done
many many things uh i've sort of
returned to doing live stand up a lot
recently
although the shows are more complex and
more theatrical than they used to be
uh i did a big show about my family
called my family not the sitcom
which uh i toured worldwide actually for
about two years
uh and it was you know i still think it
was really
[ __ ] funny show but it was moving and
complex about my mother and father or
whatever
and i also take too long i write lots of
books i've written four adult novels
seven children novels and this book that
you mentioned jews don't count is my
first
foray i guess into non-fiction it's a
polemics
quite short i'm going to get it actually
hang on it's here somewhere what have
you got it
there's one this is
just for the audience at home this is
how trigonometry shows always work the
guest just randomly stands up and walks
away halfway through
that's it and it's quite short and it's
a polemic
it's in the tradition of uh because
published by the times digital
supplement
uh of sort of without wishing to compare
it in quality to that but things that
like george orwell
wrote about i don't know what did he
write like on on the working classes
whatever orwell wrote
it's that sort of short pamphleteering
book uh and that's
what i've written recently and yet about
the failure
of identity politics specifically when
it comes to jews
and david uh i read it i very much
enjoyed it
why did you think it was so important
and so necessary
in 2020 21 to write this book
um well you know you know the question
why now you get it a lot from if you
take anything anywhere like you ever go
to pitch something to a tv commissioner
they often say why now
and i always want to say i don't know
it's just a good idea right it was a
good idea 10 years ago it's still a good
idea now
and with this book although i think it
is very relevant now and people seem to
feel it's very timely and in a way i
guess
what happened to the labour party during
the corbyn years
i don't know if i could have written it
or put it out quite so
uh thoughtfully i guess because it was
so
you know volatile all that and it feels
to me that maybe that
that now you can talk about it a bit
more sensibly although
you know it's still very volatile all
that but to be honest with you the book
itself has been brewing for a long time
you know i've been writing sporadically
in different places about what i feel is
this particular issue
which is as i say the sort of like
neglect of jews
uh within the hierarchy of racisms that
people who
are anti-racist care about i've been
writing about it since about 2002. in
fact i wrote a piece in
2011 for the daily telegraph which was
nothing to do well before corbyn and all
that
which was called how anti-semitism
entered the zeitgeist and was sparked
off by i think
when galiano uh the russia not russian i
think that's you i'm thinking of
constitution
the um galliano the what is he french
designer was found to have done gone on
a big nazi rant
author well thank you for that
comparison i i appreciate it yeah
i mean it's quite offensive to galliano
he'd never be he'd never be dressed like
that's because you're wearing a jacket
as well
what a nice wife yeah jacket nazis same
thing really yeah exactly
exactly uh so anyway i wrote about that
then and i've written about sporadically
but
to answer your question francis during
the corbyn years
there were a lot of friends of mine
left-wing friends of mine
who basically said and this is boiling
down what they said it's
decomplexifying it this can't be right
all this anti-semitism stuff because
we're we're left-wing we're anti-racists
and that's our whole thing so it just
can't be the case we don't we can't put
it together cognitively
that this is a thing and it seems to be
a thing and it seems to be really
like eating away our project but we
don't get it
i mean and so i ended up having
conversations sort of one by one with
these people
saying well maybe it's about this about
that and it's complex it's not an easy
straightforward thing people think of
anti-semitism very much as coming from
the far right
as a kind of full-on direct thing from
people who own it
who say we hate jews and we're very
proud of that and that's part of what we
like
about being this person who waves a
neo-nazi flag or whatever
that obviously is not how it comes from
progressives or the left or whatever so
it's more difficult
to pass p-a-r-s-e it's more difficult to
deconstruct
and so that's what i wanted to do all
those conversations and all those
times i've talked about it elsewhere i
wanted to sort of put it in one package
and get it out there and see what
happened and do you think david that
the the problem is and you do actually
explore it in your book is that people
associate
jews with being white therefore they
have privilege therefore you can't be
racist against them
is one of the arguments i imagine well
it's one of the arguments although i
think it's more complicated than that
and i begin i talk about the concept of
white privilege
and about a more slightly more
complicated thing to that which
which i call schrodinger's why it's not
my not i didn't invent that
uh phrase but it's a very good one i
don't know who invented it i just
noticed it being said occasionally on
the internet schrodinger's whites
is a concept whereby jews are considered
white or non-white depending on the
politics of the observer
so far-right people have i mean for
years
not just recently recently and obviously
going back a long time
considered used to be non-white i mean
absolutely set in stone
uh as part of like say white supremacy
in america is that jews are not part of
the white races
and would not be you know allowed in an
ethno state
as far as white supremacists are
concerned
uh and uh that is completely kind of
forgotten
when progressives as they tend to talk
about uh
jews and particularly when they kind of
dismiss anti-semitism because yeah it
seems as if it's just another branch of
people saying you know oh you can't be
racist against white people is
is like but you and you seem to be those
white people and therefore the racism is
downgraded
that in itself is i think a lot to do
with the fact that
jews are and i've talked about this in
the book i've talked about this a lot
the only ethnic minority who would
suffer this kind of weird
double status racism whereby jews get
all the usual stuff
they get all the low state of stuff
you're vermin
you're thieving your liars your scum all
that stuff
but they also get a high status racism
which is
you're in control of the world you're
privileged you're powerful
you are secretly controlling all
governments etc etc all the conspiracy
theories so many of them come back to
this notion of the powerful jew
and then you get this weird thing
whereby that isn't quite recognized as
an assault
as if it's sort of almost complementary
in some way
and that's i think what is also bought
by some people on the left
when they don't put jews into the
category of
people who need to protect it from
racism because they think well they're
powerful
and so they don't need it and you saw
that example with jeremy corbyn
and the mural you might want to explain
to our viewers and listeners what
actually happened with the mural what it
was and then go
into it a little bit more yeah right uh
so
this happened after jeremy corbyn came
to power but the thing that he did was
while he was still just an mp and not
uh head of the labour party and he was
2012 i don't know what you said came to
power i thought i was
i was having some kind of horrible
flashback as if that actually happened
he never came to bat you may became
leader of the opposition still
terrifying for jews uh
no i um i meant came to power
in the labour party yeah and but i think
in 2012 or i can't remember what it was
actually
in the book uh but there was a mural in
east london
somewhere uh done by an artist called
mere one and mere one is a very good
example the kind of progressive i'm
talking about because he's a street
artist
and he'd done a mural of rich people
playing monopoly sort of floridaly on
the backs of the suffering
mainly brown world poor
and he that was then complained about
by various local jewish people because
they all looked incredibly jewish they
all had sort of hooked noses
and long beards and two of them actually
were jewish too then we turned out were
supposed to be
rothschild and warburg who are these two
jewish sort of financiers who are often
brought up to keep rothschild
by people who want to say jews control
the world rothschild is really just a
substitute
for jewish control of the world
and so it got taken down the mural
uh and mere one was very cross about
that and he put out a statement on his
facebook page
saying just to confirm what i said
earlier that some
white jewish folk it's very interesting
that he chose to say white
some white jewish i think he said white
rich jewish folk but
not actually sure about that uh were
upset
by depictions of their beloved hashtag
rothschild
hashtag warburg hashtag's very important
there because he puts it on his facebook
page you click on hashtag rothschild
you go straight to conspiracy theories
about jews controlling the world so he's
done that deliberately as well
and jerry corbyn underneath his post
supported it and said it was really
you know that it reminded him of
something that happened to diego
rivera and mentioned lenin or whatever
anyway he basically
said you know there are lots of examples
of revolutionary art being taken down by
the powers that be and this is another
example of it that was essentially
jeremy corbyn's position on it
uh and later on when corbin was headed a
long part this was brought up as an
example of his
blind spot and that's a very complicated
word a blind spot in the book about
anti-semitism and my point is
that if you are a very availed
anti-capitalist
like he is you can look at an image like
that
and presumably just want to celebrate it
as an anti-capitalist
but unfortunately the imagery of
anti-capitalism
is deeply entwined with the industry of
anti-semitism
and there's really complicated reasons
for that some of them are
straightforward to do with
what i think shaw called the socialism
of fools where you know
just the way that uh some people on the
left
depict richness and capitalism and
exploitation just seems to involve
always
coming back to this image of a swarthy
fat hook-nosed bearded man
counting his money and then but in the
book i suggest it might have even deeper
unconscious reasons to do with christian
imagery
and you know unable to separate kind of
gargoyles and evil from the image
from the face of the jew but my point is
to a jew and also i think to a sort of
ordinary educated person
that image of that mural looked a lot
like
the cover of desterma which is the nazi
newspaper that was published weekly by
julius streicher and always had a
cartoon
of essentially jews celebrating
their control of the world uh but he
corbyn
kind of couldn't see that and i think
that and neither could mere one by the
way
which i think is as as important in its
own way that someone so
self-avowedly i'm off the left i'm of
you know a person who fights injustice
blah blah blah
couldn't see it and in fact was angry at
it being taken down
so francis actually came up with but
it's going to sound better coming from
me because unlike him i'm jewish
and he doesn't have a racist voice
exactly for both of those reasons but do
you think that
um the allegations of anti-semitism
against jeremy corbyn and the labour
party under him
uh were exaggerated and weaponized by
his enemies
um well i talk about that in the book uh
i talk about how
um the book is you know short but i try
for me the truth is always complex and
actually one of the things about
you know podcasts like yours i think
that's good that you know
i said this before we started that i
wrote a piece about the culture wars in
um the sunday times and i talked about
being asked by and
you know do excuse me for saying this
but uh you were one of the ones in my
mind
uh being asked by alt-right podcast to
go on uh and
let's just make sure we put that in
inverted comments some people who don't
get the joke
right um but the but reason that uh that
i
would be you know even though maybe you
know
do you would you say that that would
have any truth at all is that just
unfair no
no absolutely not so how would you
describe yourself in terms of your
relationship to progressive thinking
we uh i would say that we oppose uh
we're anti-work
we oppose wokeness for the same reason
we oppose the far right and they
hate us equally too yeah so we actually
get a lot of anti-semitism including him
he's not even jewish he just looks at
because the far right hates us as much
as the far left
because and we'll get into this because
i do have something i want to
to argue with you about which is the
merits of identity politics at all
yeah let's go let's park that because
that's yeah
i know yes i've had that conversation a
few times and yeah
we should talk about that but my point
was the truth is always complex
right and i think you know that's
something that that you're demonstrating
in your answer there right
uh that actually this idea of easy
tribalism
is bollocks uh and one
way in which i try to make that clear is
that i think that anti-semitism was of
course weaponized
by the tory party during the time of
corbyn and i used the example of matt
hancock
uh getting into trouble at some thing
where he was talking about the nhs
and flailing really badly because he you
know
it was clear the nhs were not being
supported properly and
he just mentions corbyn anti-semitism as
a result
to try and get out of it and then what
happens is the crowd start
booing and stamping their feet and
taking the microphone away from him
and just laughing at him and i pointed
out
that when i was troubled by this on
twitter which obviously
a lot of my book is about social media i
just got immediately shouted down by
progressives can't you see he's
weaponizing it can't you see he's
playing card and i wanted to say yeah
this is a cognitive dissonance thing
he is doing that i am still as a jew
disturbed by this mob's reaction to the
word anti-semitism
it is impossible not to be as a jew to
hear someone say
what about anti-semitism however you
know
[ __ ] is that he's done that to hear
them stamp their feats and boo and
dismiss it
violently as a thing that would ever be
of any concern
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website
well if you do then easy dns are the
company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record
of standing up for their clients whether
it be council culture
d platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies
he knows a bit about that so will you in
a second easy dns of
rock-solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off of the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
well since we've got into the into that
identity politics conversation we might
as well
get on with it this was uh so i found
your book very good and i think
you the way i felt was you identify
the dots but then refuse to connect them
in my view
and i'll tell you what i mean by that
right so for me
it's it's the inevitable consequence of
identity politics
the jews will be perceived as evil
oppressors
just like east asians will be the
chinese japanese koreans
basically any culture that teaches its
children to
to value education to work hard at
school and as a result of that
succeeds will always be seen as the
oppressor because
as far as i'm concerned identity
politics is about
splitting people into groups and then
going these are good groups these are
bad groups
and the bad groups are the ones that do
well the good groups are the ones that
are struggling
right um do you what what would be your
view on that that sort of position
well okay so the book is
not a road map uh i've had this a few
times
a few times where people say to me um
you know are you suggesting that
the intensification of identity politics
that are so swirled around
other minorities should be applied in
every way
to jews and is that a good thing for
jews to be on the same kind of hair
trigger
sort of radar for offense and whatever
and my answer to that is that is not
the book is not that the book is not a
like a piece of social planning right uh
it is an analysis
of the way things are and i'm very kind
of like assiduous in the book and way
not to make any kind of like easy value
judgments
about those things my position is this
is how it is
i mean your point exists
because you know you you are critiquing
identity politics because you
feel it as a very happening thing
right all those things you've just
talked about now
i think the book is more valuable
because there's been lots of sort of
like uh
attempts to take apart identity politics
that are somewhat really good and some
less
less good or whatever but i don't think
you get to
in a way the people i'm trying to speak
to if your position is
identity policies politics is [ __ ] right
and these
are doing in a way i think all i take a
neutral position
on the book which is this is what it is
right we live at a time where the
language of privilege and
uh the intensification of uh
microaggressions against uh identity are
taken very seriously
by you know these people who feel
themselves the guardian of that stuff
and yet they miss out jews or they have
a different attitude to jews they're
ambiguous around you so for example
which might make it clearer i talk in
the book how
it's very much as uh you know a
commandment if you like an article of
faith
for uh let's call them woke
people uh that uh you know the
the um people who are discriminated
against can define the racism
uh so you know a white person should not
be telling a black person
that isn't racist right and i would
agree with that
to be honest with you uh but my main
point is whether or not i agree with it
it exists that's definitely something
piers morgan gets shouted at
but online if he tries to tell meghan
markle that something isn't
racist uh right or whatever that does
not apply to jews
right they're they're ready david the
reason i ask you the question is you
repeatedly describe yourself as a
progressive
in the book and i think you've already
said so yourself so i guess
what i'm asking is how do you square
that circle of on the one hand
uh you know wanting to talk about this
issue on the other hand
supporting a world view which i would
say will continue to contribute to
discrimination against jews
well because i think that i'm a
progressive but also the book is a
critique of progressives
right so i mean actually i met with
someone yesterday
who said to me that he read the book i
don't particularly see it exactly like
this because i don't think in a way it
goes even into this area but he said
that the book at some level
takes apart the whole idea of identity
politics because without
saying it because if it doesn't work for
jews
and as you say may not work for others
then it start then obviously the whole
thing starts to
fray right but meanwhile he read it like
that
at the other end i got a review in the
times by stephen bush
uh who is a left-wing guy and i think
he's politically headed for a new
statesman
in which he said to me i mean a bit more
like you're saying i guess
he said to me oh he's left-wing but he
doesn't believe in the language of
privilege
right he's a mixed race jewish and black
guy doesn't believe in the language of
privilege doesn't believe in the whole
concept of white supremacy and
structural oppression and all that kind
of stuff i might be simplifying but
that's the impression i got
um and he and he said oh you you know he
essentially accused me of adhering
to those ideas in the book i said no i'm
modeling them
i'm saying this is how they are and now
i'm critiquing them i'm really not
applying any kind of value judgment to
them either way now i'm happy
to some extent because the book is
supposed to just be attaching to a
conversation
to say for people to take it either way
to be honest you because
it's a short book and it's
tactically an intellectually i think
more useful
to say this is how it is this is how
identity politics is it misses out jews
here's the complex reasons why it does
that
and then i've noticed and this is just
empirical
the progressives who read it just say oh
[ __ ] yeah
right now i'm not sure they'd do that
if it was like and identity politics is
you know
[ __ ] up in all these other ways and
also
to be honest with you my own thinking
about that
is complicated you know i think and i
yeah so what is your own thinking about
that tell us
that's what i really want to get to is
what is your own thinking about that
yeah but that's
okay but that's weird that you want to
know that constitution i think you want
to know that
because i think you do want to weaponize
the book as part of the culture wars and
i don't want to weaponize it for
anything i'm just curious how you think
about it because
foreign but that's my point it is
complicated
and that's what i'm i'm trying to work
it out in my head still that's what i
want okay so
i think okay so so look so so at one
point i'm having this conversation with
stephen bush
because i say he's a mixer a jewish
person of color right and
at one point he says something light
because i say in the book
he appears to completely reject the
language of privilege even though he's
of the left and whatever and i say at
one point something like
uh in the book i talk about jews not
being white
right um not being quite white in the
way that i've described
um and there's other reasons why i talk
about that as well including personal
kind of lived experience ones like being
beaten up myself
once one of my first stand-up jokes was
i've been beating up twice in my life
once being jewish one to being a
pakistani and
those that that stuff that just happened
to me right i had something very similar
in my routines as well talking about how
on the same day i was discriminated
against for being a pakistani
and then later i got an email from a gig
for a comedy show saying oh we've got
too many white men on the bill
right it was about me well that's a
perfect bit of schrodinger's whites i
have to say
yeah exactly but but but in that same
bit
i say that i agree that being white
brings you privileges in society that
the white person may not be aware of
right and i do agree with that you may
not but i do
agree that it definitely gives you
certain head starts in life
and certain other ones it may not give
you when you refer to you know that you
have to complexify with well what type
of white person
you know boris johnson as a white person
has had enormous privileges that a you
know
northern irish working-class bloke you
know has not had
right so that's what i mean by
complexity i adhere to some of it but i
think you always have to complexify it
well i agree with that that's so there's
no element of this show that's about
weaponizing anything david i just wanted
to make
make everybody understand that i'm just
curious about how you think that's all
yeah well that's i don't know how else
to put it really then i think that
well okay so here's another example
slightly adjacent to what you're saying
but i think it might help
so i get asked a lot and i have talked
in my shows about
what is okay and not okay to make jokes
about
right and obviously that's something
that you've talked about as well right
and i say you can joke about anything it
depends not the subject matter
but the joke right so actually in my
last show about trolls i tell a number
of holocaust jokes one
particularly one particular one and say
this these jokes are not offensive
right they're not and not just because
i'm jewish and have relatives who were
killed in the holocaust
look at who's actually been targeted
here these are not jokes these are not
pro-nazi jokes
nor are they laughing at the victims
they are jokes complicated jokes that
might make people feel less alone or
they might
i mean i'll tell you the joke that i use
right which is an old well
i don't know how old it is but it was
not it's like a traditional joke someone
told it to me right
and uh it's about a holocaust survivor
who after the war uh dies of natural
causes sometime after the war goes to
heaven
when he gets there god asks the survivor
to tell him
a holocaust joke so the survivor does he
tells god a holocaust joke
and god says that's not funny and the
survivor says well i guess you had to be
there
i love that joke i love that joke
because you know it's funny but it also
says something very
profound about the absence of god in the
years 1939-45 right
that's a holocaust joke you can tell it
so my point is
you have to examine it on a joke by joke
basis you can't just say you can't tell
jokes about wherever and i would say the
same thing really about identity
politics
i would say it works sometimes and it
doesn't work at other times and you need
to look at
the specifics that's a good point and
david wouldn't you say that identity
politics just
increases divisions within people and
it's in many ways just a form of divide
and conquer
it just get you know we always say that
francis not always no
sometimes i think that is the case and
sometimes it's not it depends again on
the community you're talking about
uh sometimes on the individual you're
talking about you know
um i think it definitely can become that
and there are times when i read [ __ ]
that's happening and i think yeah that's
totally happening
and other times i think like you know i
mean to use an example right i'm reading
um satnam sengara's very brilliant i
think empire land
right which is about the british empire
and there's like
a thousand things in that book i didn't
know about as a british person which is
primarily what i feel myself to be by
the way and all the [ __ ] that's in my
past i feel myself to be a british
person quite proud at many levels of
being a british person
uh and yet i read i read this book stuff
about the amritsar massacre that i don't
know
anything about right and then i do think
and this is an identity politics way of
thinking okay these voices have been
silenced
so you know until now in the discussion
of what it means to be british and in
british history
it's a good thing that that's
complexifying and i really don't agree
with those people who get furious about
it
and feel that you know he's just
complaining and
you know what blah blah blah i mean he
himself said
uh of a ipso mori poll that came out
quite recently
which asked the question are you proud
of being
uh of the british empire or are you
ashamed of the british empire
all right that's a stupid question
because history is not a football team
you know you don't just support it or
feel bad if you lose
you basically you know try and absorb
new ideas into it as time goes on right
yeah yeah and moving moving on now david
one thing that i found particularly
interesting in the book was and
particularly because i'm a football fan
and it's a word that has been used many
many times throughout football
is used by tottenham hotspur is the is
the word yid
and you were saying that it's a racist
word and lots of people have been
discussing it
since time memorial why is it to you
that this word
is a racist word well the primary thing
about that again
everything i say in that book needs to
be seen in context
so we you know over the 40 years
that i've been going to football you
know it started as an incredibly racist
environment
and lots of work was done by football
and by uh organizations like kick raced
about football whatever to change that
uh so that by the time you get to 2010
which is the story i tell about that in
the book
it's already in the program it says that
any racist abuse
uh will need to be a banning for life so
that's the context
in which i'm talking about the y word
right uh it's not just
you know is this a racist word or it
isn't although we can argue about that
separately it's we live in a time of
very high awareness of offense of those
words right
so my question is not really is that
word racist it's
why is it not considered racist given
how
[ __ ] offended we are by all these
other words right so that's
so then what happened was in that
particular case is me and my brother are
at chelsea
and we weren't even playing spurs for
anyone who doesn't know because this is
a global podcast
right tottenham hotspur they are a
football club uh
they i uh you not everyone for tom
hartsford but
some of them uh own the word
yidd because tottenham is a jewish area
and they feel that you know they've
claimed that as an identity and blah
blah blah
and their own position on it is that
that's somehow you know
a nice use of the word right uh
and my whole point about that is has
happened in this case
is well there's a number of things
involved firstly most tottenham fans
aren't jewish
right it's a myth that tottenham fans
are jewish uh there's like if if
five percent of what used to be why art
lane
uh you know is jewish that would be
massively more
there's only like naught point three
percent of the country are jewish
so if five percent of them were jewish
that would be loads of jews that means
95 percent of them
chanting the word ye the yid army are
not jewish
right so that would be the first ever
reclamation
of a hate word by people who are not
part of that minority and as i've said
before
the equivalent is you know if there had
been a club in a black area say brixton
or whatever
that had you know decided mainly white
fans
decided we're going to adopt the n-word
as our identity and
enchanted n-word army that club would
have been shut down
like 20 years ago i mean i have to say
the comedian in me would like to see
that
yeah you wouldn't see it i mean you
could just rename it milwaukee
yes yeah
so um so basically what
the story i tell in the i mean you know
this totally like happened a lot chelsea
and it was always really depressing
when yodo started because tottenham
some tottenham fans i think it has
shifted a bit but anyway some tottenham
fans
celebrate that as their identity right
and say it's a really positive thing but
what they're not listening to
is the fact that arsenal fans and
chelsea fans and millwall fans of west
ham fans
it comes back that identity with menaces
with like auschwitz chance spurs are on
their way to auschwitz
and hissing to represent gas chambers
and in this one particular case
as i say we weren't even playing spurs i
think spurs were losing to hell are you
a spurs fan
by the way who uh either of you
i i support west ham he supports everton
okay fine
so we i think it was they were losing to
hull and it came up on the scoreboard it
was a boring game we were playing villa
and the crowd just started chanting you
know you know
over and over again this incredibly
aggressive non-celebratory way
and then a bloke behind us just starts
shouting [ __ ] the [ __ ] yids
[ __ ] the [ __ ] is over and over again
and then blasting through
this notion that by yids he just means
tottenham fans that's fine he doesn't
mean anything else he just changed it
to [ __ ] the [ __ ] jews over and over
again
and in terms of the context that i'm
talking about after about
10 minutes of this my not very old
brother
either stands up and says shut up mate
right and he says no [ __ ] off and
there's
about to be an enormous fight and then
he just does stop
iva sits down and says i think i'm going
to cry which i wish it was very
sort of funny but also kind of moving
but the point is no one says anything
no steward intervenes there are no that
bloke is not banned for life
and me and my brother have to try and
create a film which we call the y word a
short film
to raise awareness so this is happening
which is hard
to get made keep racing about football
at first and not interested don't want
to do it they've got
more important things to talk about is
it really a problem that's what i'm
talking about in the book
and actually to come back to your point
about identity politics right
that is really a violent form actually
of anti-semitism
right it's properly violent when you
hear a crowd and
lots of people join in or whatever and
whatever your thoughts about identity
politics it's a real [ __ ]
hole in it if that is just ignored and
invisible and whatever
and so you sort of have to whatever your
uncertainties about identity politics
grasp the nettle
of identity politics and say okay if we
are living at a time where
aggressions against minority are a
problem
then can we apply it to this ethnicity
as well please
i just think you have to do you have a
business
do you want to make the most of your
business do you want to advertise online
but don't know where to do it well how
about you advertise with trigonometry we
have
over 200 000 subscribers across the
different platforms
we sometimes get up to three million
views a month for our videos
and it's a great opportunity to showcase
your product so if you
want your product or business to stand
out amidst
all the nonsense that is happening drop
us a line
at marketing trigger pod dot co
dot uk that's marketing trigger pod
dot co and we will do our very best
to help your product stand out and when
we say stand out what we really mean is
get cancelled no i totally agree with
you that
there's a lot of inconsistency and
double standard
in that philosophical way of thinking
about the world i
i totally get that my concern about
identity politics and i actually
really like the point that you made
about how
it's not a universal thing there's
different elements of it and sometimes
it might be appropriate
for example the the civil rights
movement in america
in the 60s was an example of identity
politics
right but the way it was conducted it
was made inclusive
so it wasn't about antagonizing groups
against each other so you're right
you're right there's a new ones to this
and what i would say is
my concern about identity politics comes
much more from
the way it's done as opposed to the
concept in general i think there's
nothing wrong
with people who are members of a
particular group of having
an identity that encompasses parts of
that as well
my worry is that we now live in a world
where groups are being pitted against
each other that's what i think we oppose
on the show um
so i'm really glad you know i don't
agree with that and i and you know
obviously you know every day
you see like shades of it you see like
you know
where as you said certain girl like the
other day in the lancet
whatever they find out why the lancer
wants to get involved in this [ __ ]
it's a medical journal but the other
thing in the lancet there was a
suggestion
to asian americans that they should
sort of not take pride in
being successful within the medical
community or whatever
because that allows racists to say oh
look here's a minority that's doing well
and that can be weaponized against other
minorities right and you kind of think
like
this is written by a white person not an
asian american who are you to tell
asian americans that they can't take
pride in their own achievements do you
know what i mean
and that's just stuff where you think
it's it's
yeah it's mental do you not think as
well and this is coming from my own
perspective of it and people who
were watching this on the show would
know of this i'm actually
technically could argue mixed race my
mother's latin american grandfather was
an arab
so on so forth from venezuela my problem
with identity politics is this
it's incredibly reductive i believe it's
what it does is it boils people down to
in fact what are
the most unimportant parts of them what
i think is most important who you are
how you see the world the way you
conduct yourself
and by just saying you are part of this
group
it's incredibly shallow way of thinking
because
yes but it's far more complicated than
that there has
i think it is it is when all it is
really
is a way into shouting right yeah
if it's just a way into shouting about
like you know i'm more oppressed than
you
and you know i hate you because you're
more privileged
or whatever then then it's no use at all
all right
but i think you know firstly i don't
agree
you know with it being useless i think
there are forms of structural oppression
yeah
that affect people of color and that
also affect other people
you know that there are gender issues
and all sorts of things
they do exist right yeah inbuilt
prejudice it does exist but in a
different way
as you speak i i have to say i don't
agree
because i i don't agree that identifying
yourself in a certain way necessarily is
reductive
when i put you as my bio on my twitter
feed
that's enormously complex because i'm
not religious
yeah that's something we haven't even
discussed but i'm an atheist
uh you know and i'm always having to
explain two [ __ ]
on the internet that anti-semitism is
not religious intolerance
it's racism because the gestapo would
shoot me tomorrow
right and i and i'm an atheist i don't
believe in god at all
right yeah but i do have a very
complicated and quite difficult to
describe certainly to non-jews
identity that i feel very strongly of
myself as a jew but it's not simplistic
it's not reductive but so i would push
so i would just and all we're doing is
talking about our experiences as well
i'll be honest with you but i'm really
loving this conversation so people would
say to me oh you're white you've never
faced racism
my mother wanted to call me francisco
jaime foster police my
i grew up in a lower middle class
working class part of south london
my father was worried about raising my
chains i used to work at a garage when i
graduated from
university doing admin as a way to
er money and uh there was a very racist
uh
racist uh there was a lot of people in
there with very unpleasant racist views
to the point where
i actually when mom gave me a lift
sometimes in the morning she had to park
around the corner
because i didn't see the want them to
see the fact that my mum was brown
i know what it's like to have members of
my family been racist
racially abused me and my cousin got
chased when we went to watch a football
match
and i find when people go oh you're
white therefore you're this if you've
never experienced this i'm like no
that's
the completely reductive way of thinking
and it's
it doesn't allow for the complexities of
human emotion
or in fact race i would agree with that
because that but that comes back to what
i was saying earlier
which is you know just as you have to
examine jokes on a case-by-case basis
you have to examine people
on a case-by-case basis you know and
there are
people you know and i've used boris
johnson's a [ __ ] easy example of it
but i would say he still is an example
of it
who you know have lived their life
with all sorts of privilege primarily
class privilege primarily
money privilege but him being white is
part of that it's in the mix as well
uh because he just wouldn't have been
you know in his generation
you know he wouldn't have found it very
easy to get into eaton and all that
is that true though what about rishi
sunak well he's younger
uh i don't i i don't if it's true
it seems like you know this is a new
thing you're talking about
which is partly to do with identity
politics you know the fact is
rishi shunak is brown and he's
privileged right but
when i was growing up you're younger
than me both of you but there was no
[ __ ] chance of a brown person big
chance of this checker when i was
growing up
uh at all which is a different argument
by the way
to the fact that i put something out in
the book which is that i personally
think that
you know it's an interesting thing that
jews have never thought of as bain
you know it's a much derided acronym but
jews theoretically are bane
uh because of minority ethnic uh which
is what that means and i very much do
think the jews are an ethnic minority
so meanwhile i noticed that whenever
bame is celebrated like for example
sajid javid being the first uh brown
chancellor
i say no that's nigel lawson right i
felt first brown chancellor but the
first bain
chancellor was nigel lawson in my
opinion right but no one ever
would grasp that as a thing it's a so
it's partly you know
the whole jewish thing is partly about
that as well it's about representation
and celebration not happening
it's partly about that too but i totally
agree what you just said francis
which i'd say was really moving right
yeah right
is exactly what i just said about
complexity
the truth is always complex so yeah you
can pass as you know people always
saying jews can although i don't think
i can really i don't think constantine
can but people are always saying
jews can pass as white or whatever you
can pass as white right
so that doesn't mean that your history
is like
easy you know and actually the example i
use a bit in the book
i hate i sort of hate the hierarchy of
racism but i'm gonna use it a bit like
if you wanted to sort of actually
place jews and whatever uh sort of
people who are not immediately
apparently someone who might fit into
identity politics
it's worth thinking about gay men or i
suppose gays in general but gay men are
more
more apparent in a way for the argument
which is they have white privilege
right uh they are generally economically
fairly secure
right but who's gonna say which
progressive is gonna say
so you're probably all right as long as
you don't tell anyone as long as you
stay in the closet
you're probably all right are you so
[ __ ] shut up about homophobia no
one's going to say that
are they but that is sort of said to
jews you know
it's sort of an anti-semitic science
society people sort of say well you know
no one really knows jewish so just keep
quiet about it and then you're right
yeah yeah david it's it's all
interesting i'm really enjoying this
conversation as well because i think
uh all of us might have come into this
conversation with slight misperceptions
about each other and we're sort of
flattening them out as we go which i
really like
i think it's great and um about that by
the way
i i don't any misconceptions i had about
you which i probably
but i sort of didn't really you've seen
what i mean i was sort of taking the
piss earlier
when i said about yeah like podcast
that's all right actually i'm good man
i've seen you do
stand up and i wouldn't be doing this
podcast if i just thought you were
you know just a bald or right i know
that you're you've still
he's going to be seething about that for
days thank you david i really appreciate
this is why i never
actually like jews
no okay that was the wrong one was an
ill chosen word
right and it wasn't in my subconscious
in any way
because i'm looking at you it wasn't
right
you know i i know that you that you're
you're you know
from your stand up that you're a
thinking bloke and that's the point
really the point is that
the whole culture war thing gets
devolved into non-thinking responses yes
yeah yeah and that's why i you know i
really hope
a lot of people watch this interview
because i think this is how you talk
about this sort of stuff
but david it's a great book i don't want
to let you go just yet it's a brilliant
book i recommend people
get to and think and discuss these
issues actually in the way that we've
been having
but if you don't mind i did want to take
a few minutes because all three of us
being comedians
and i remember when the whole count
dankula thing happened you took a
what to me was an interesting position
someone who who
simultaneously describes themselves as
progressive but also
is a thinking person and you know you
talk about you can joke about anything
what is your view
of this heated discussion we've been
having in the comedy world
about freedom of speech versus making
sure we don't offend people and all of
that where do you come down
on that well as i said earlier
i think you have to look at it on a joke
by joe basis
so with cal dankula i mean actually i
wrote quite a lot about that because i
changed my view
about that but not completely well no
not completely
so my first position which i was on
ricky gervais's podcast
was uh this is obviously or can it can
so
could easily be seen as someone taking
the piss out of nazis
because yeah i believe there actually
was someone who was arrested by the
nazis
do you know about this you probably do
yes because they taught their dog how to
do a nazi salute and
the nazis took that fair enough in a way
i mean you often hear that with the
nazis but fair enough
as taking the piss right yeah and that's
what it seemed to me
when i first saw it right teaching your
pub particularly a pug
to do that and then someone got in touch
with me and said no but
you don't really understand the nature
which maybe i didn't at the time of [ __ ]
posting
right and the idea that [ __ ] posters do
this thing
which i do understand more now of sort
of subsuming
really hateful right wing ideas uh into
lols right into like oh we're just being
funny
and blah blah and he showed me this um
uh
you've probably seen it thing from i
can't remember what the website's called
now it's called something like the daily
stormer
which is a kind of manual for ship
posters
which basically says if you want to get
[ __ ] hating ideas out there do it
under the cover of comedy right and
pretend it's all just
plausible deniability because i was just
having a laugh so
so i then wrote another piece well i
i've done the ricky thing and then i
wrote a piece for the tls
in which i said oh right i'm folding all
this into my thoughts
i still think uh probably in this case
it's mainly funny and i quoted peter
cook and dudley moore
who i think on derek and clive peter
cook says something about
watching the dangers of watching nazi
stuff
and he said it's terrible because you i
watched stockholm the other day
and then before i knew i'd gone down to
golden screen and massacred about 200 of
them
right and there's no question i think
that's funny
not least because again on a joke by
joke basis
yeah he's taking the piss out of he's
not taking the piece out of massacring
jews
he's taking the piss out the idea that
people can be so easily influenced right
that's what he's saying the piss out and
that's what my thinking is always you
always have to see where the joke is
well the thing with dankel of course the
police did go through all his
online communications and they found no
evidence of any kind of prejudice so
i think in his case the evidence would
suggest that he was just a joke
uh and i've met the guy and he doesn't
seem like a bad guy to me but look
that's that's personal
but what about the broader conversation
do you think
comedians should be you know wary of
offending people or do you think it's
just
quite a bunch of snowflakes ruining
comedy like those seems to be the two
polar opposites
yeah i don't think either of those
things yeah i think also you have to
you know i mean i do think that comedy
is obviously much more police now than
it used to be and i think that is
an issue and uh you know
some of the time i think it's a
conversation and it's a conversation
that's worth having
and some of the time it does it's more
you know what i sort of worry about it
more with the second guessing than i do
with the thing itself
if you see what i mean so it's less for
me about like oh here's an example of
someone who got really attacked and
whatever
because he did this joke or whatever
that is what is that doing to the
writing of comedy or the thinking before
you even do the joke
and i think that is a worry i think that
a lot of people including myself
now when about to sort of put pen to
paper with a joke or
whatever thing oh yeah but what are from
all sides
x y and z gonna say you know
are they gonna find bad intent in this
joke that isn't there
and that i think isn't that i think
isn't good for comedy because i think
you need to have a kind of freeform
ability to just say what you feel
and then maybe like you know deal with
the fallout but the sort of like
stifling of your head beforehand i think
is a really bad thing
it is and if when you think about the
greatest comedians the communities that
we all love and respect whether you know
the richard price patricia and neil's a
bill hicks whoever it may be
you know they they certainly didn't have
that filter yeah well
i don't i mean i was turned on to comedy
by derek and clive
that's why sort of why i'm a comedian i
don't know if you know it that well
uh that one yeah right okay
but that for me what i thought was funny
about that and brilliant about that and
still do
is it was two blokes with no filter
like just quite drunk improvising both
of them
comedy geniuses particularly peter
curculo so with study more in my opinion
and as a result you get this
unbelievable you know
level of sort of extreme tourette's like
swearing and obscenity and whatever and
it's [ __ ] hilarious
you know somebody probably hasn't dated
that well
but i still think of it as really
[ __ ] hilarious and
that's my worry is that that side of the
brain is being closed off
yeah it is a worry isn't it and that
self-censorship that you talk about is
the thing that i think
i think a lot of people feel and look i
i really admire you for saying it
because
i know that as a progressive that isn't
the mainstream view necessarily on that
side of the spectrum
yeah but i mean you keep saying as a
progressive i mean what i am
is as with jewishness and as with the
humanity that france talked about
earlier
you know i'm just i mean politically
i've said this for a while i think of
myself as sort of
i think that was a progressive but i am
basically
no wing for a long time now i was i
would have described myself as left wing
growing up very much so but now i think
of myself
as my main thing is original thought
that's my thing right and by original
thought i mean
and certainly as regards politics but
perhaps possibly with everything
i'm not gonna have a pre-arranged
ideological map
that i'm gonna impose on any issue i'm
gonna look at the issue
and i'm going to look at the question
that's being asked to me and i'm going
to think what do i [ __ ] think about
this
yeah not i'm a left-wing person so i
have to think like this about it
right so that that's always been how
long for a long time how i've been
trying to think all right well that's
good to know that that's
that's right that is how we try to think
about stuff as well and i think
look all of us fail at that right all of
us sometimes we all fall into ideology
but you i mean the only reason that just
as an apology the only reason i called
you progressive is that's how you
describe yourself no you don't talk too
much
i do describe myself as a progressive so
that's why
probably in terms of the uh you know i
think
because i do agree with some of that
stuff yeah sure
absolutely but david it has been a
pleasure and an honor and it's
i will say open one of my favorite
interviews it's been absolutely
brilliant we close our interviews always
with the same question which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society but we really should
be
i think it's constantine's baldness
i'm glad i brought it up now because it
really isn't being mentioned enough
yeah absolutely i don't think we talk
about it enough we should we should talk
about it more
we should in fact we should talk about
it outside the scope of trigonometry it
gets discussed on trigonometry quite a
lot
but i think we need to broaden out the
conversation antoine is our producer
anton darling could you turn that into a
meme please
let's not forget don't worry anton
doesn't need to someone else will take
care of it i was asked the question
and i said it without self-censoring
knowing it might cause a fence
but that's brilliant that's really
that's what i love man
uh david thank you very much for coming
on our alt-right podcast
we appreciate it
i hope i hope you've managed to put up
with anti-semitism
on the show well uh it hasn't
traumatized you too much
it's been great it's been really
enjoyable thanks guys very enjoyable
chat
david thank you so much for coming on
jews don't count is the book
uh please go and get her it's available
everywhere
and we will see you very soon with
another brilliant interview like this
one
or a live stream all of them go out 7pm
uk time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below